people who are like super villains or
whatever they always are depicted
holding cats that's nuts how could you
be compelled to dominate the world right
now I never want to move again
hello I'm Hannah Hart host of Food
Network's I heart food and today I'm
gonna be answering your questions with
some extra special guests do we can we
get more kittens I actually have three
cats in my lap one two three the last
one is asleep Eddie's hiding
I started out my drunk kitchen as a joke
for a friend
I was a proofreader working in a
translation firm I had just moved from
San Francisco to New York and a friend
of mine he's a friend of I was going
through a little about of depression and
I just wanted to make a joke to cheer up
I will have all the cats we'll get every
single kitten that's here yes
[Music]
I hurt food visa show that about going
to different cities across America and
seeing how each of those areas highlight
local ingredients how many ways can you
cook a lobster isn't it all basically
the same that's something we explore I
[Music]
think the best thing I ever made well I
made souffle and it wasn't that hard
guys so that's all I have to say about
that and the worst thing I ever made
what's nothing no regrets I don't think
it can be an online creator you know I'm
going 60 or strong and I don't think you
can look back and think that you made
any big mistakes unless of course you
did and then you make an episode called
my drunk kitchen whoopie pie where you
explain that you're sorry I say we do
this for every interview you guys like
this oh my god I think I like this
[Music]
no restaurants it really dangerous
investments and I'm more of a put your
money under a mattress type of person
now would I ever consider opening up a
cat cafe yes
just be cool don't get too excited this
is the key to making content you just
let it happen if it's gonna happen and
if it's not oh my god it's happening all
the kittens are here every kitten is
here
it was here for a moment and I'll
believe that moments captured in time
[Music]
I would say you're perfect exactly as
you are and you already know that don't
let anyone teach you otherwise also take
as long as you need
I always feel like there's a lot of
pressure to come out but you should come
out when you're safe and sound you know
when you feel like you're in a
physically and emotionally safe
environment and you have this a support
group then come out don't come out just
because people are saying why aren't you
coming out already Oh like take as long
as you need it's your journey nobody
else's you guys smell so fresh and so
clean clean
are you out cat hi do you like puns
if so then your love I heart food
[Music]
yeah Britney Spears was a real in SPO
for that right you guys look at this
well vas what did you hear what did your
elf eyes seek did your fi sleep this
bouncing ball cuz that's what I see
definitely cats I also believe in
kitties and puppies and babies hello
hello I love you won't you tell me your
name
yeah it's kitty dun dun dun Donna Donna
Donna oh hi guys
not big fans or the oldies I'll tell you
that right now happiness means
appreciating what you have and staying
present in the moment
and not always thinking about what you
don't have baby too cute I really like a
step science I think that they're really
crushing it right now obviously my
friends grace mamrie Tyler I think
they're all hilarious Jon Cozart aka
pinked I really like minutephysics I
don't know what he's up to these days
but minutephysics was really great
hello boom mmm he he doesn't know that
I'm really paying attention to him he
thinks that he's got me but I've got him
I just love answering this man's
questions over here definitely not
trying to get this kittens attention is
it working I would say my go-to drink in
college was whatever was available
and/or nearby in college you really
can't be picky but you can drink
responsibly
[Music]
Malibu coconut rum I don't think anyone
can drink that anymore because of
college you're in it took it t cute and
sweet it's okay to go sleep sleep just
you were with you t everything yes
you're kicked deep hey girl hey just so
you guys know these adorable kittens are
all available to foster or adopt at the
ASPCA go to SPCA org slash foster la
quick before I just take them all with
me
[Music]